Oh
my name is Marco Cochrane and I'm
sculptor and we're in my studio here on
Treasure Island
I moved to Treasure Island to get larger
space and because i was going to do a
40-foot figure and this building has
high enough ceilings too not just stand
the pieces up but to work in scale I
used pantograph that was invented in
1602 and still works very accurately I
used to do enlargements of sculpture the
old-fashioned way before computers took
over and now commuters doing there's a
new technology that daughter disqus
kotnis set up this cult photo fly and
you take photographs of a
three-dimensional object all around it
and email them to them and they send you
back a pretty high res 3d scan of the
thing that changes the game completely
for me anyway because I have wanted to
do but I work in clay and there's
there's areas where the the piece is
beautiful during the process and back
before this I'd have to stop make a mold
of the piece destroy it basically by
doing that fix it start again and
sometimes it's only 20 minutes later
that I want to do it again so I've been
waiting all this time to to be able to
just photograph it and then keep going
the lighting system for bliss is LEDs
addressable LEDs so their control will
buy computer and we have at Burning Man
we had an ipad application that would
play you could run the lights and now we
just came out with a iphone application
to you go out there and change they'll
make the lights do their thing on your
iPhone you can pick colors & paint the
the internal and then these are the
external lights so you can change the
color of the external lights and since
it's empty you can light it internally
you can let it externally and if it's
only external it looks solid it's like a
solid metal thing and if you let it
internally you can see through it and
backlight you can see right through it
it's practically not there but if you
mix the external light and the internal
light it's crazy the scale of it I had a
sense of what it would do being that big
would overwhelm the conscious brain and
throw you into a different state and it
does it kind of trips you out like you
can't figure out how big it is or how
big you are and and that it lets that
feeling in of real serious contentment
and joy and that's what the world needs
you